Transcriber: ÖZGE İŞBECER
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Herkese merhaba.
Hayatınızda en unutamadığınız
anı getirin aklınıza.
En mutlu olduğunuz,
en çok heyecanlandığınız.
Ben hayatımda unutamadığım bütün anları
futbol sahasında biriktirdim.
Peki aranızda futbolla ilgilenen kaç
kişi var çok merak ediyorum.
Görüyorum ki çok fazla kadın el
kaldırmıyor bizim ekip hariç.
Peki futbol dendiğinde
aklınıza ne geliyor?
Şöhretli erkek futbolcular,
büyük transferler.
Aynı soruyu bir de kadın
futbolu için sorayım.
Aklınıza eminim ki çok fazla kadın
futbolcu ismi gelmiyor.
Veya takım adı.
Bugün burada karşınızda bir kadın futbolcu
olarak duruyorum ve bu alanda ne
kadar zorluklar yaşadığımı ve bu
zorlukların bana getirdiği güzel şeyleri,
güzel anıları sizlere anlatmak
için buradayım.
Hayat hikayemi anlatmak için buradayım.
Ben Didem Karagenç.
Beşiktaş Kadın Futbol Takımı ve
Kadın A Milli Takım Kaptanıyım.
Futbola başladığım yaşlar
hiçbir ailenin hadi benim kızım da
futbolcu olsun diyebileceği
zamanlar değildi.
4-5 yaşındaydım.
Bir futbol topunun peşinde
tutkuyla koşturuyordum.
Ailem çalışıyordu ve beni babaanneme
bırakıyorlardı.
Aynı yaşta bir kuzenim vardı Erdem.
O da babaanneme geliyordu.
Biz sabahtan akşama kadar birlikte
futbol oynuyorduk.
Tabii bu evde futbol oynama serüvenimiz
bir süre sonra artık yaşımız büyüdükçe
sokağa inmeye başladı.
Sokağa indiğimizde şöyle
bir şey fark ettik.
Erdem'i hemen oyuna dahil ettiler
ama beni almakta zorlandılar.
Çünkü sokağa çıktığında benden başka
hiçbir kız çocuğu futbol oynamıyordu
ve ben bu ayrımı
ilk defa orada fark ettim.
Ama kuzenim Erdem bana çok güveniyordu ve
erkekler beni oyuna almadığı zaman onlara
şöyle bir şey söyledi.
Dokuz aylık oyunu var.
Belki biliyorsunuzdur; işte en az
çektiren kaleye geçer.
dedi ki Didem de
bizimle beraber top sektirsin.
Eğer Didem bizden iyi sektirirse o da
oyuna dahil olsun dedi.
ve bunu kabul ettiler.Tamam hadi sektirsin
görelim falan dediler.
Ben de top sektirme başladım.
Ve hepsinden daha iyi sektirdim.
Hayatımda ilk defa kendimi futbol
konusunda ispatlamak zorunda kaldım.
Aslında bu hayatımda ilk defa olan şey.
Benim hayatım boyunca devam edecekmiş.
Tabii bu yaşlarda onun farkında değildim.
Ben eğitimci bir aileden geliyorum.
Babam öğretmen ve tayin nedeniyle
Sakarya'ya gitmek zorunda kaldık.
Sakarya’nın Sapanca ilçesine gittik.
Babamla artık öğretmen öğrenci
ilişkim başlamıştı .
Aynı okuldaydık.
Ben teneffüslerde, koridorda her yerde
futbol topuyla oynuyordum
ve erkeklerle oynuyordum.
Bu durum etraftakileri rahatsız
etmeye başladı...
işte...dediler ki yani kızınız
futbol oynuyor falan babama.
Babam dedi ki oynayabilir
bir problem değil.
Biz sorun etmiyoruz.
Kızım oynayabilir.
Ve okul futbol takımı kuruldu.
Ben okul futbol takımına girmek istiyordum
ama biliyorsunuz ki erkekler
genellikle futbol takımında oluyor.
Kadınlara yani kızlara özel
bir futbol takımı yoktu.
Ben de erkeklerin olduğu takımda
oynamak istedim.
Çok o kadar çok ısrar ettim ki babama,
babam Milli Eğitim Bakanlığına gitmek
zorunda kaldı ve bana izin
almak zorunda kaldı .
Tabii bu söylediğim şey şu an izni aldı
ama size şu an çok kolay geliyor olabilir.
Şu an bile gitseniz belki
bu izni alamazsınız.
Burada anlatmak istediğim aslında şu.
Ailem benim yanımdaydı ve benim
destekçimdi bana aldığı o özel izinle
benim aslında futbol hayatıma
start noktasında bir başlangıç noktasını
vermişti babam.
Çünkü ben turnuvalara katılmaya başladım
ve turnuvalarda gerçekten çok iyi bir
performans sergiliyordum.
Herkesin dikkatini çekiyordum.
Bir maçta kornerden iki tane gol attım.
Bu golü izleyen bir hoca varmış dışarıda
dedi ki işte bir kadın futbol takımı
kurmak istiyoruz.
Seni de çok beğendik
biz seni...
gelelim akşamleyin babana söyleyelim,
alalım dedi takıma.
Ben tabii sevinçten havalara uçtum.
Dedim ki çok şükür hani bir takım bulduk.
Yani sonunda bir yere gidebileceğim,
ben de sporcu olabileceğim,
futbol oynayabileceğim.
Babama söyledim, babam dedi ki:
‘Akşam gelsinler’
Arkadaşlar hiç hayatımda istenmemiştim,
ilk defa istendim çünkü
ellerinde çikolatalar, çiçekler evimize
geldiler ve dediler ki işte kızınızı...
Sakarya Güneş Spor’a istiyoruz.
Veriyor musunuz?
Babam dedi ki:
‘Alın gidin zaten başımıza bela!’
Çok istiyor oynamayı lütfen dedi.
Hani biz istiyoruz, oynayabilir.
Hep babamdan bahsettim, annemden
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Çünkü hayatımın kahramanlarından
bir tanesi de o.
Annem futbol oynamak istiyormuş çocukken
ve sokaklarda futbol oynuyormuş ama dedem
izin vermediği için bu hayali
hiç başlamadan bitmiş aslında.
O da benim hayallerimi
gerçekleştirmek için her zaman yanımda
durdu, bana destek oldu.
Hala da yanımda destekçim her
deplasmanımda yanıma geldi.
Tıpkı bir antrenör gibi her yerde
benim yanımdaydı ve beni
desteklemeye devam etti.
Bizim artık ben 11 yaşında lisanslı bir
futbolcuydum ve artık profesyonel hayatım
başlamıştı.
Sakarya’dan, Sapanca’dan Sakarya’ya bir
saatlik bir yolculuk yapmak zorundaydık.
Çünkü arasının biraz mesafesi vardı.
Aracımız yoktu, dolmuşa biniyorduk.
Her akşam oraya gidiyorduk ve artık
Sakarya'dan da tekrar futbol sahasına
gitmek için ayrıca bir yola gidiyorduk
ve akşam bizim eve dönüş saatimi saat
11-12′ydi ve kesinlikle
babam hiçbir şekilde bu
durumlara bir şey demiyordu.
Böyle devam ederken tabii ben şimdi size
profesyonel dedim ama asla profesyonel
bir sahamız yoktu.
Bir futbol oynamak için gerekli malzemeler
yoktu, formamız yoktu,
antreman kıyafetlerimiz yoktu.
Sadece bir tane topumuz vardı .
Bir de fabrika sağolsun.
Arkasında normalde kendi çalışanları
halı saha maçı yapıyormuş.
Bize o sahayı verdiler.
Akşam vakti gittiğimiz için tek bir ışık
yanıyordu ve araba farları vardı .
Tek bir ışığın altında işte 15 tane kız.
Orada spor yapıyoruz, futbol oynuyoruz.
Bu bir süre böyle devam etti ama yani
burada şöyle bir nokta var.
Tamam antreman yapıyoruz, performans
gösteriyoruz, bu kadar emek sarf ediyoruz,
gidiyoruz, geliyoruz. Bir şey eksik,
ligimiz yok, bir maçımız yok.
Yani aslında hiç sonunu bile görmediğimiz
bir yola ailem beni götürüyor ama sonunda
bir maç yok.
Neyse birazcık yavaş yavaş
kıpırdanmaya başladı.
Bir turnuva düzenlediler çünkü on tane
daha takım vardı o zaman Türkiye’de.
onu öğrenmiş olduk.
Hep beraber turnuvalara gidiyorduk, ancak
turnuvalarda oynayabileceğimiz
bir formamız yoktu ve yol masraflarını da
karşılayamıyorduk.
Şimdi hazırsanız Türkiye’nin ilk
sponsorunu açıklıyorum size kadın futbol
sponsoru; bir marulcu abimiz vardı.
Ve bize... halde çalışıyordu.
Dedi ki: ‘Ben size sponsor olacağım!’
‘Ama sadece bir şartım var!’
Üstünüzde benim ismimi yazacaksınız.
Tamam dedik yani ne yapalım?
Hani ‘Marulcu Orhan’. Her yere gidiyoruz,
bütün eşofmanların üstünde Marulcu Orhan
Marulcu Orhan.
Kim bu adam?
yani ne işi var orada bizim üstümüzde. Ama
sağ olsun emekleri büyük ve onun sayesinde
otobüste gittik geldik.
Ve Sakarya hikayem aslında yavaş
yavaş sona eriyordu.
Üç sene boyunca oradaydım ama hiç
bir resmi müsabakaya çıkamadım.
Babamın tayini nedeniyle tekrardan
Ankara'ya döndük.
O zamanlar Ankara’da Gazi Üniversitesi’nin
bir takımı vardı ve
bu takım gerçekten kadın futbolunun
en üst seviyesi idi.
Çünkü akademik anlamda çok iyi
antrenörlerin çalıştırdığı bir takımdı.
Biz annemle gittik işte Doçent Doktor
Mehmet hocanın kapısını çaldık.
Dedik ki oynamak istiyoruz takımda falan,
al kızım gel dedi, lisansımızı aldık,
gittik oraya başladım orada oynamaya.
Avrupa düzeyinde bir eğitim
aldığımı söyleyebilirim.
Çünkü hocalar gerçekten çok iyilerdi ve
6 senelik Gazi Üniversitesi hayatımda
çok fazla şey sığdırdım, 4 şampiyonluk
sığdırdım.
Bunlardan en sonuncusunda Şampiyonlar
Ligine gittik.
Neden en sonuncusunda gittik?
Çünkü Türkiye’nin o zaman katılım hakkı
yoktu Şampiyonlar Ligi’ne ve biz UEFA
Kadınlar Şampiyonlar Ligi'ne katılım hakkı
verildikten sonra giden ilk takım
ünvanını elde ettik.
Yıldızlarda oynuyordum, gençlerde
oynuyordum ve ilk Milli Takım'a da
burada seçildim.
O maçlarda dikkatini çektim hocaların.
U15 Milli Takımı'na seçildim ancak
çok fazla müsabakası yoktu U15
Milli takımının.
Şimdi yetenekli bir sporcuydum işte.
Sol ayağımı kullanıyordum
iyi olduğumdan dolayı,
kendimi övmek gibi olmasın ama on beş
yaşındayken on yedi yaşına gittim.
On yedi milli takımına gittim.
On yedi milli takımında oynarken kendimden
büyük olan 19 milli takımına,
19 milli takımından A Milli Takım’a gittim
ve bu süreç bu şekilde devam etti.
Ve şu ana kadar da halen devam ediyor.
Halen milli takımda görev
yapmaya devam ediyorum.
Ankara Gazi Üniversitesi de Şampiyonlar
Ligi'ne gittikten sonra şöyle bir algı
oluşmaya başladı insanlarda.
Uluslararası arenaya gidiyorlar ve
bu çoğu kişinin dikkatini çekti.
Bazı belediyeler bu işin
içine girmek istedi.
Çünkü kendilerinin isimlerini o mecralarda
göstermek istiyorlardı.
Kendilerini oralarda
tanıtmak istiyorlardı.
O yüzden Konak Belediyesi dedi ki:
“Bir takım kuruyoruz biz.”
Kim, en iyi sporcular kim?
Milli takımdaki sporcular.
O zaman dediler, biz onları alalım,
biz Türkiye’de şampiyon olalım,
Şampiyonlar Ligi’ne gidelim, orda da
bir derece elde edelim.
Bu amaçla bizi İzmir'e topladılar.
Şimdi ortaokuldan beri size hiç
eğitimimi anlatmıyorum.
Tabii bu sırada lise bitti.
Üniversiteye başladığım Beden Eğitimi
Öğretmenliği bölümü mezunuyum.
Aynı zamanda öğretmenim de şu anda.
Çünkü sporcu iken hayatımızı devam
ettirebilmek için mutlaka ek bir meslek
yapmamız gerekiyordu.
Ben de babamın mesleği olan öğretmenliği
seçtim ve eğitici olarak çocuklara
bir şeyler öğretmek istedim.
Benim artık yolculuğum başlamıştı,
ilk defa hayatımda resmen transfer oldum.
Sakarya’dan Ankara’ya geldim, Ankara’dan
İzmir’e transfer oldum
ve benim için
şöyle bir yolculuk başladı.
Eskiden 1 saat gittiğim yol
8 saate çıktı.
Çünkü artık Ankara'dan İzmir'e
gitmek zorundaydım.
Otobüse biniyordum, dersten çıkıyordum.
Haftanın üç günü Ankara'daydım.
Otobüsten indikten sonra İzmir'de
hemen antrenmana koşuyordum.
Eğer o hafta deplasmanda ise şanslıydım.
Çünkü maç İzmir’deydi.
Deplasmansa bir daha yolculuk
yapmak durumundaydım.
Orada çok iyi işler yaptık.
Üç sene üst üste şampiyon olduk.
Şampiyonlar Ligi’ne katıldık ve
Şampiyonlar Ligi’nde
son 32 takım arasında kaldık.
Son 32 takıma kaldıktan sonra son 16
takıma kaldık ve son sekiz takıma kalma
maçında elendik.
Bunlar şöyle oluyor arkadaşlar,
deplasmanlı oluyor.
Gidiyorsunuz, geliyorsunuz.
Bizim İzmir’de oynadığımız müsabakalara
inanılmaz iyi reklam yaptılar.
İşte bütün İzmir halkı artık bizi
tanıyordu, otobüse biniyorduk tanınıyorduk
ama 4 bin kişi geldi
oradaki seyirci olarak.
Yani kadın futbolunda 4 bin kişi
çok büyük bir sayı idi o zaman.
Bu kadar başarı elde ettik.
Çok da iyiydik.
Şu an size sorsam belki hiç haberiniz
yoktur ama bir erkek takımı UEFA
Şampiyonlar Ligi'nde bir gruptan çıktığı
zaman ülkede değişen çok fazla şey oluyor.
Yani haberler onlara yapılıyor.
Gazetelerde boy boy fotoğraflar, resimler
tüm gündem bir anda değişiyor.
Bizde öyle bir şey olmamıştı.
Artık yani orada şöyle düşünmeye başladım.
Büyük camiaların mutlaka bu işin
içine girmesi gerekiyor.
Burada çıkan haberler bu şekilde.
Ama sadece bizim yerel gazetelerimizde
çıkıyordu bu haberler.
Büyük camiaların bu işin içine birazcık da
girmesi gerekiyor, değişmesi gerekiyor.
Ve bu esnada 2015 yılıydı.
Ben okulumu bitirdim, mezun oldum.
Artık öğretmen olarak atanacaktım.
Beşiktaş Kadın Futbol Takımı kurmuş,
üçüncü ligden bu işe girmişler
ve ikinci lige yükselmişler.
Ben de karar verdim.
dedim ki Beşiktaş takımında bu büyük
camianın, takımın formasını
giymek istiyorum ben.
Bu amblemi taşımak istiyorum.
Onların taraftarlarına karşı oynamak
istiyorum ve oraya transfer oldum.
Normalde birinci ligden bir alt lige
düşmek bir milli futbolcu için
çok zor, zordur.
Ama ben ilerisini hayal etmek istedim.
Çünkü büyük bir statta
futbol oynamak istiyordum,
ikinci ligdeyken namağlup şampiyon olduk.
Daha sonra birinci lige yükseldik.
Birinci ligde şampiyonumuzdan sonra erkek
takımının maçında devre arasında
bizi sahaya yani sahaya soktular ve
dediler ki kupanızı burada gezdirin,
kaldırın, gösterin  tribüne karşı
sizi tanısınlar.
Neyse biz de aldık kupayı geziyoruz.
Herkes bakıyor ve bunlar ne
takımı, çünkü bakıyorlar...
voleybolcuya benzemiyoruz, basketbolcu
hiç değiliz, hentbolcu mu falan.
Sonra anons geldi işte dediler ki
bunlar bizim futbol takımımız.
Yani tabii ki bilenler vardır aralarında
ama çok büyük bir bilinirlik oldu,
artmaya başladı .
Biz şampiyon oldukça başarı kazandıkça
daha da artmaya başladı, daha da çoğaldı.
Ve aslında olayların değiştiği nokta
şuydu. Biz bir maç yaptık.
Atletico Madrid-Beşiktaş .
8 Mart Dünya Kadınlar Günü'ne özel
Vodafone Park'ta bir maç düzenlendi ve bu
maçta 33 bin kişi stadı doldurdu.
Bu yani bizim için inanılmaz bir andı.
Çünkü bu kadar emek verdiğiniz bir yolda
hiç yolun sonunu göremiyorsunuz ve hayal
bile edemeyeceğiniz bir noktaydı aslında
burası.
Çünkü size anlattım işte hikayemi
kendimi ispatlamak zorunda kaldım.
O fabrikanın arkasında bir
sahada oynuyordum.
Ailem beni çok zor şartlar altında
götürdü getirdi
ve onlara şunu sorduğumda
cevabını veremiyorlardı.
Ben bir gün bir statta futbol
oynayabilecek miyim?
Bunun bile cevabını veremezken ben
stadyuma çıkıp bu kadar seyirci önüne
çıktığımda ailem beni orada izliyordu.
Bu benim için çok büyük bir gurur, onurdu.
Yani bunca emeğin karşılığını almış gibi
rahatlamış hissetmiştim kendimi.
Çok güzel bir anı benim arkadaşlarım için.
Kendimizi ilk defa futbolcu
gibi hissettik bu arada
onu da  söylemek istiyorum.
Daha sonra başarımı uluslararası arenada
artık göstermek istiyordum.
Milli sporcuydum, milli takımda, Avrupa
Şampiyonası’nda, Dünya Kupası’nda
ülkemizi daha iyi yerlerde
temsil etmek istiyordum
ve global arenada
kendimi göstermek istiyordum.
Tam bu arada Londra'dan teklif aldım ve
her ülkeden bir kişiyi seçiyorlar.
Türkiye'den de beni seçtiler ve ben artık
bu takımın içinde yer almak için hazırdım.
Bu global sözleşmeden sonra
şöyle bir şey oldu.
Bu ilk Türkiye'deki bireysel sponsorluk
sözleşmesi idi ve Vodafone Park'ta bir
lansman düzenlediler benim için.
Bu benim için çok unutulmaz bir andı ve
sonrasında global taraftan telefonlar
almaya başladım.
Guardian ve BBC
benimle röportaj yapmak istedi.
Artık tamamen vizyonum ve
misyonum değişmişti.
Milli takım kaptanı olarak o gazetelerde
artık ülkemizi tüm dünyaya
anlatabilecektim.
Bu gerçekten benim hayal bile
edemeyeceğim bir noktaydı
bu işe başlarken.
Benden sonraki kız çocuklarına ilham
veriyor olmak, cesaret veriyor olmak
mükemmeldi.
Milli takım bazında ilk defa, 100.
formayı giyen futbolcular arasına girdim.
Bu erkekler için de çok zor bir başarıdır.
Yüz defa milli takım formasını giymek,
yüz tane maça çıkmak, yüz kere milli
marşımızı okumak, dinletmek
gerçekten benim için.
hani şu an anlatıyorum ama çok duygusal
ve çok önemli anlardı bunlar.
Biz kadın futbolcular olarak bundan sonra
gelecek olan genç arkadaşlarımıza, genç
kardeşlerimize destek olmak için, onların
hayatlarında daha iyi şeyler
yapabileceğini göstermek için buradayız.
Ben işimi tutkuyla yaptım, işimi
tutkuyla yaptığım için de sonuçta
karşılığını aldım.
Tabii ki ailemin buradaki
katkısı yani çok büyük.
Onlar olmasaydı bunu asla başaramazdım.
Bundan sonraki hayattaki amacım da kadın
futbolcu olarak benden sonra gelecek olan
gençlere ilham vermek, cesaret vermek.
Ve onlara yapamayacakları hiçbir
şeyin olmadığını göstermek.
Ben ve takım arkadaşlarım bunun için
uğraşıyoruz ve uğraşmaya da
devam edeceğiz.
Bu önyargıları yıkmak için elimizden gelen
her şeyi yapacağız ve kadınlara
yapamayacağınız hiçbir şey
yok dedirteceğiz.
Şimdi size küçük bir hediyem var.
Bunu bir kişiye hediye
etmek istiyorum.
o topu geri alacam yalnız.
Unutmayın.
Bu hayatta doğru ayakkabıları giyerseniz
yapamayacağınız değil.
Doğru ayakkabılar, bir kadına doğru
ayakkabılar verildiğinde dünyayı bile
feth edebilir.
Ben bu anlamda doğru ayakkabıyı
giydiğimi düşünüyorum.
Çok teşekkür ederim.